أنت في المنطقة الساخنة ، لذا فإن هؤلاء المرضى
على سبيل المثال يتلقون الأكسجين منخفض
التدفق من الأكسجين B: هذا المريض على
الجانب الآخر لديه تدفق عالٍ من
العلاج بالأكسجين بحيث لا يقوم هذا المريض بعمل
جيد وهذا د.  يلين ديكمان ، التي ترأس
وحدة العناية المركزة في جامعة إسطنبول ،
تدفع جدة بكل الطب إلى واحدة من
أكثر الطب ازدحامًا في البلاد ، لقد كان طبيبًا في وحدة العناية المركزة
لمدة ثلاثة عقود ، لكن لا شيء
يضاهي
ذلك ، فهو شديد جدًا في الوقت الحالي ، ولا أحد
يعرف حقًا إلى أين يتجه هذا الفيروس.
يجب أن يكون هذا مخيفًا بعض الشيء
في بعض الأحيان
مخيفًا من الناحية الفكرية ولكن لا
بأس ، لكن علينا أن نفعل شيئًا
ونحاول أن نبذل قصارى جهدنا ولكننا نحقق
نتائج جيدة جدًا في الواقع ،
لقد نجحت تركيا بمفردها من خلال
بروتوكول العلاج الخاص بها مثل  تأخير
التنبيب واختيار علاجات تدفق الأكسجين
لفترات أطول من الوقت
إدارة اهتزاز اليرقات عبر
مضادات الفيروسات اليابانية وهيدروكسي كلوروكين ،
دواء الملاريا المثير للجدل في وقت مبكر جدًا
والذي يقول العديد من الخبراء إنه يمكن أن يسبب
ضررًا طويل المدى يفوق
فوائده غير المثبتة ولكن الفريق هنا يقول
إنهم  لست قلقًا من أننا
نتعامل مع أحجية الصور المقطوعة
وحاولنا فقط العثور على القطع الصحيحة
ووضعها فيها  المكان الصحيح
ونفعل شيئًا ما ونأمل أن يكون
هذا المريض في الأربعينيات من عمره مع عدم
وجود حالات مسبقة لذلك
تمرض الرئتان أحيانًا بشدة ولا يمكنها توصيل
أي أكسجين إلى الدم ثم من
أجل إبقاء المريض على قيد الحياة
لإخراج الدم من الجسم
وتزويد الجسم
بالأكسجين ، يتم ضخ الدم المؤكسج للمريض مرة أخرى إلى
جسده ، كل شيء عن التواجد هنا هو مجرد
مكثف حقًا ،
فالآلات تنفجر باستمرار وهي ترتدي هذه
المعدات الواقية ويجب أن أقول هؤلاء
الممرضات هؤلاء الأطباء هم حقًا  يتمتع
الموظفون بأعصاب من الصلب ، فإن الموظفين
متفائلون بشكل مدهش
لأن المستشفى ليس غارقًا على الرغم من
القفزات اليومية في الحالات الإيجابية في
الآلاف من المساحات في جميع أنحاء البلاد على عكس
بعض مناطق الولايات المتحدة أو أوروبا ، لا
يوجد تخزين في مساحة سرير معدات الوقاية الشخصية أو
المعدات الطبية المنقذة للحياة حوالي 70
من الموظفين أثبتت إصابتهم بـ
kovat 19 bushland أو Chuck mock
وكان من بينهم ممرضة في غرفة الطوارئ كان هذا
هو أول يوم لها بعد عودتها إلى الوظيفة لتكون في مرتبة
الشرف  لا أستطيع أن أقول إنني لا أخشى
أن الأمر مرهق تخبرنا ، لكنني
الآن أكثر حذراً مما كنت عليه من قبل
[موسيقى]
بغض النظر عن مدى صعوبة عمل الموظفين هنا
بغض النظر عن مدى استعدادهم
للتدفق الذي يأملون أن يفعلوه  لا يحدث أبدًا ،
لا يمكنهم التغلب على هذا الوباء بمفردهم
الذي توقفنا عليه جميعًا أروى دامون